(upbeat techno music)
- It's now time for
the Hashtag Wars.
(buzzer dings)
Kirkman.
- Bum Raisin Ice Cream.
- Okay, points.
Braunger.
- Frozen Brosgurt.
- Yeah, points. Ugh!
Jen Kirkman.
- Splinterdoodles.
- Yes, points. (audience laughs)
Jo.
- Pee Lime Pie. My favorite.
- Points. Braunger.
- I'm sorry.
Strawberry Abort Cake.
(audience laughs and groans)
(audience applauding)
- [Chris] Justin Willman.
- The Count of Monte Cristal.
- Yes. (laughs) Points.
Mamrie.
- Horton Hears a Who Dat.
- Yes, points. Mamrie.
- Ludachristmas Carol.
- Points! (audience groans)
Justin!
- Lil Women.
- Points.
Jonah.
- A lotta people walkin' around
like they got somethin' to say,
but nothin' comes out
when they move their lips.
Just a bunch of gibberish,
like they forgot about
50 Shades of Dre.
- [Chris] Points!
(buzzer dings)
Thomas Dale.
- American Horror Story.
- Points. Mary Lynn.
- Unenthusiastic
birthday blowjob.
- Points. (laughs)
Your birthday or the
other person's birthday?
- You know what it is.
- Okay. Kurt.
- Turnip for (bleep).
(audience laughs and groans)
- Points.
Thomas.
- Yes we can.
- Hey, nice, points. Mary Lynn.
- Bed, bath, beyond.
- Points.
Kurt.
- Lion King soundtrack.
(laughter)
- Would that be
the, would that be,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
Would that be the
Circle Jerk of Life?
(laughs)
- Hey, Hakuna Matata, man.
- [Chris] Hey, alright!
Yes, Scott Aukerman.
- Meats by Dre.
- Yes, points. (laughs)
Brett.
- Microsoft Penis.
(audience laughs and groans)
(audience applauding)
- Points.
- Thank you.
- Scott.
- Three Ways.
It just gives you
directions to a three way.
- Oh yeah, perfect. Points.
That's not ruining anything.
Brett.
- MacBook Pro Joe Piscopo.
- Oh my god. (audience laughs)
A Joe Piscopo reference?
- It's so good. (buzzer dings)
- Jon Daly.
- Human Fleshlight.
- Yes, points.
Scott Aukerman.
- iWatch you pee.
- Yeah. You're playing
the game now, right?
- Nah, I'm just telling.